this morning our series the dish visits
the south carolina low country to meet a
long-time cook who's being honored for a
lifetime of service to our community
emily megan is 89 years old and she just
published her first cookbook it
celebrates the food and culture of the
gullah gucci descendants of western
central africans who are enslaved and
brought to the lower atlantic states
jerika duncan traveled to edisto island
near charleston to meet the author and
cook
it's a welcome sign to anyone looking
for a home-cooked meal so you have an
open door policy open door walk right in
all you have to do is make a little
flower on it at 89 years old maggot or
miss emily as she's known around edisto
island cooks daily and she's always
prepared to serve extra whether for one
or in this case 100. my grandmother said
don't never cook just enough for you
always cook more because you don't know
who's going to walk in that door wow
it's good there's something about this
chicken on this small island of about 2
000 people everyone seems to know miss
emily in fact the owner of the local
market doesn't charge her for anything
because tomorrow she'll have squash for
us or biscuits or cornbread she's dead
in my heart and many others in this
region she's
one of a kind local chef b.j dennis
considers her the matriarch of this
community the history the food the
culture
all that is wrapped up in emily megan so
edison island emily megan just go hand
in hand
we spent some time with miss emily in
her kitchen and watched as she prepared
casserole baked chicken that's it no
watch the magic and red rice how do you
know how much to use
imagination imagination your brain and
your heart
from okra to yellow squash salt pork and
seafood miss emily's gulligici culture
has influenced all of her cuisines
this is good it's a culture that goes
back to her enslaved ancestors whose
experience growing rice in africa
allowed south carolina's low countries
economy to flourish
to this day red rice is a gullah staple
where does your love for cooking come
from my grandmother was a cook
and she taught me how to cook
because i didn't like going out in the
field to work so she would say you stay
home and you cook
clean the house
and then bring us our lunch at the age
of 22 emily took a job at this mansion
she washed dishes for the dodge family
earning just 11 dollars and 15 cents a
week it was fun
it was fun yes it was yeah
until
i had to do that cooking what was the
hardest dish for you to get right when
you first started really biscuit the
biscuit was the toughest one oh i
couldn't get that biscuit right for
nothing but the head cook at the house a
gullah woman named julia brown helped
megan with a dash of tough love if i
didn't do it right
she would throw it in garbage can she
said you're going to do it right and if
you don't do it right you're going to do
it over again and i did it over over and
over and over but i got it right she
spent nearly 50 years working there
12-hour days all while she and her late
husband jessie raised 11 children how
did you do it i guess by the grace of
the good lord
when the mansion was sold miss emily
spent summers cooking for becky smith
and her family she has this amazing
ability to
make the cooking look like it's
just nothing effortless and she can do
it and talk
and give you stories and wisdom and
engage i just thought this is one
incredible woman and just said to her
emily the world needs to know you about
two decades ago smith began encouraging
miss emily to write a cookbook but that
meant reverse engineering nearly 200
dishes taking recipes from miss emily's
imagination and putting them to paper
the result miss emily's life her cooking
and culture all boiled down to this
282-page book
[Music]
in april the community threw a party for
their favorite cook
turned author with people lining up not
for a meal but for an autograph it was
amazing
it's the most wonderful thing to see
someone who's lived her life
just in such a quiet yet powerful way be
so honored it's the most wonderful thing
to witness
and just last month another memorable
moment on behalf of the american people
i extend my heartfelt appreciation to
you she received the president's
volunteer service lifetime achievement
award
he did it all we are just so grateful to
god for what he has done
at this beautiful age of 89.
she never imagined her cooking would
lead to this but when love is baked into
everything you serve there's always a
craving
for more
good work
wow
emily loved everything about her yes and
her story and i love her red hat and her
red outfit and she's sitting there
talking she is sharp what a treasure
on all fronts and the family they were
so welcoming i plan to go back there
they they invited me back with you okay
charleston that's such good food oh yeah
bring this back for us i did bring this
back you're right tony i did i actually
got there took
is dynamite
okay dynamite is it you really like it i
really like it it's gonna be gone thank
you show 844 stick around here's the
thing
the rice is a little hard i'll be honest
no no no you like it like that yeah
uh-hum you must put it in the pan when i
i called miss emily's daughter laverne
several times yesterday wow and she
encouraged me and told me as long as the
flavor's there you're good as my
relatives say you put your food your
foot in this bunions and all right
i don't get that at all this is
delicious
i would say the coffee you know i got a
bunion
flavor's definitely there thank you